vice president-elect kamala harris is
preparing to move to the u.s naval
observatory
that's the official home of the vice
president she will be
the first female black american and
asian american vice president
to ever live there at the u.s naval
academy in annapolis there will be
another
historic first midshipman first class
sydney barber is her name
she will be the first black woman to
serve as a brigade commander
in the academy's 175 70
175th year history think about that 175
cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller spoke with her about her
new leadership role
[Applause]
this spring senior sydney barber will
earn her stripes
rising to the highest rank at the u.s
naval academy
brigade commander leader of all 4 500
midshipmen here
the first black woman to hold that role
i'm extremely humbled to play a role in
this moment of history
for the 21 year old illinois native it's
all still
a bit overwhelming for a black female to
be
taking command of an institution that
once never had
a single female at all
here let alone a black person it speaks
volumes
to how far we've come barber's legacy
began with her father
lieutenant kenneth barber a 1991 naval
academy graduate
to mark your name in 175 years of
history of the u.s naval academy
is quite humbling and i'm proud that
she's going to be part of that long
history
a trailblazing history barber becomes
only the 16th woman to serve in the top
job since the academy went co-ed
in 1976. the same year her mentor janie
mines became the first black woman
admitted me being here at the naval
academy
is her wildest dream to be able to to
lead in this capacity and i hope that
one day i could be someone else's
wildest dream
you were telling me you almost
didn't go out for this yes you're right
i almost didn't what pushed you over the
edge
to push the button my sponsor mom
captain tasha lacy
she really spoke it into life captain
tasha lacy an academy alum
couldn't let this opportunity sail by
for barber
we only go for things that we think is
within our grasp
i never thought that i could be the
brigade commander and so consequently
didn't apply for that
job and so when i saw sydney getting
ready to go that same route i'm like oh
no ma'am
no ma'am you have to go for
the stars and barber has been going
nonstop since high school traveling
abroad on mission trips for her church
an experience she says led her to the
academy
i'm blessed in so many ways that i have
i have to give back
i have no other choice but to pursue
service to others
a member of the gospel choir she also
holds an academy record
in track and field still there are times
when she doubts herself
and that's when she turns to her brother
justin i would say
if there's anyone in my life who's
inspired me most it's him
born with a rare condition that has left
him blind and deaf
justin was given less than two years to
live
we celebrated his 19th birthday this
past
may he just reminds me that every single
day is a blessing
every day is a gift i can't take for
granted a gift
she shares with her classmates and
generations of leaders
to come what i want to do is just to be
someone else's light to be
someone that people can look at and say
i can do something that's greater than
myself
and make a change in our world
and in america for cbs this morning
michelle miller new york
bravo bravo thank you michelle miller so
nice for her to introduce
what an impressive young woman i won't
forget her won't forget her name
and i love the mentor who said to her oh
no no ma'am
go for those stars it's my favorite line
in the beginning it's so important to
have somebody like that yeah
our service academies and all service
branches have so many great people and i
love them we have an opportunity
it's one of them so